hey what is up everybody it's animac
here for anime uproar and this is
completely crazy somebody please check
on horikoshi because the latest events
in mha just made the villains way too
powerful Dobby is on an unhinged Rampage
and burning everything in sight using
shoto's ultimate move phospher toga is
swarming the heroes with Sad Man's
parade and Prime All For One is using
these events to execute the Final Phase
of his master Bland Hawks and Endeavor
are on the brink of death and many other
Heroes and hero students are
unfortunately right there with them so
let's get into it guys do me a quick
favor if you like our videos leave a
like and comment right now it only takes
you a second but it helps me out with
that YouTube algorithm and well over 50
of you guys who watch our videos are not
subscribed now if you like our videos
and you click on them regularly take the
time to subscribe right now maybe you
think you don't need to because YouTube
recommends you the videos anyway but
eventually they will stop unless you
subscribe and you're gonna miss a ton of
our content finally this video will
contain mha manga spoilers so please
proceed with caution you have been
warned oh and finally finally I'm
recording this video in the middle of an
actual blizzard so if you hear any weird
sounds in the background that's what
that is the previous two chapters made
it clear that the villains shifted the
balance of the war decisively in their
favor after the successful release of
kurogiri kurogiri didn't waste any time
and he brought toga and adabi to all for
one's location and of course toga
immediately started using twice as Quirk
after that kurogiri teleported to UA
with the intention of freeing shigaraki
from the effects of izawa's Quirk
Erasure these few quick moves by
kurogiri completely changed the game on
both major battlefields and the heroes
of course struggled to react and respond
to such a sudden and dramatic shift in
the balance of power things would soon
get worse from there because toga then
fully initiated Sad Man's parade and an
infinite number of twice clones
assaulted the heroes the only small bit
of good news for the heroes is that
ochako and tsuyu also managed to hitch a
ride through kurogiri's portal and are
now at gunga but if we're being honest
you know we can love Ocho and Julio's
characters but that isn't much
reassurance for the heroes who are now
dealing with all for one berserk mode
Dobby and Sad Man's parade at the same
time in the latest chapter we see ochako
trying to calm toga down by getting her
to talk about love something that toga
had always wanted to do in the past
that's because toga considered ojoko to
be her friend and she wanted them to
talk about their Mutual crush on Deku
but of course ochako never considered
toga her friend because toga is a cruel
and ruthless villain who hurts people
without a second thought now toga could
never understand why ochako didn't
approve of her actions since toga can't
understand that what she is doing is
wrong so in her own mind she actually
feels betrayed by ochako and Deku she
feels that their inability to understand
her and their unwillingness to support
her is almost a betrayal of their
friendship and even though that will
sound insane to most people it all makes
perfect sense in toga's Twisted mind and
because toga feels betrayed she is no
longer responsive to ochaku's attempts
to get through to her she says that
there is no longer a girl in love here
and she refers to ochako Simply as hero
rather than by her name as all of this
is happening Sad Man's parade rains down
upon the heroes the heroes are trying to
keep the horde of twice clones back but
there's just too many of them and
ultimately the heroes are forced to
retreat in fact Sad Man's parade isn't
even the only problem that the heroes
are dealing with Dobby is now also there
and he is going absolutely berserk and
burning down everything in sight the
heroes are essentially stuck between
Dobby's flames on the one side and Sad
Man's parade on the other and they are
quickly running out of options ochako
and tsuyu managed to meet up with
tokuyami and Jiro and they are all in
agreement that their situation is dire
they have to do something or else the
heroes and hero students here on the
gunga Mountain Battlefield are all
doomed and of course once the heroes
here fall the villains will turn their
attention to the rest of Japan and the
way that things are going Dobby's flames
and toga's Sad Man's parade May engulf
the entire country it is now clear that
the initial divide and conquer strategy
of the heroes has failed and as a bunch
of twice clones attack Endeavor Dobby
levitates through the air on top of his
flames and mocks his father and I can't
emphasize this enough but this is not a
normal looking Dobby he looks like an
unhinged burning nomu and he is also
using shoto's ultimate move phosphor
that move which combines both ice and
fire into one single Force if you watch
this channel regularly then you already
know that I've been saying for a while
that Dobby is not human after he was
consumed by flames on secretary Peak and
taken in by all for one and ujiko the
villains performed many procedures on
him in order to save his extremely burnt
body they wanted to save him because of
his unusually powerful Quirk and they
performed the same types of procedures
on him that they used to create the nomu
even so Fujiko thought that Dobby would
be dead within a month after he left the
facility where they had been keeping him
and yet more than eight years later he
is still alive still using his Quirk and
still surpassing all limits we can't
forget that little Toya was born without
a strong resistance to fire so after
repeatedly pushing his Quirk to the
Limit his body should have been burned
up long time ago and yet he's still here
and as dangerous as ever my theory is
that the modifications ujiku and all for
one performed on his body made him into
something more than human he became
someone who has a human mind but also
the Superhuman body of a normal now
these superhuman Powers obviously don't
extend to his skin because it has been
damaged but clearly the core of his body
is not just a normal human body not
anymore that is my theory and I'm
sticking to it anyway Endeavor asks his
son whom he calls by his birth name Toya
about Shoto he wants to know if Shoto
survived the scorching battle against
his brother in kamino the unhinged Dobby
says that he wanted to bring him shoto's
corpse as a present but unfortunately
Shoto was too strong and Dobby was
unable to kill him so that part of
Dobby's dream the part about killing
endeavor's favorite son right in front
of him will have to go unfulfilled
however Dobby still plans to kill
Endeavor and exact his revenge and as
all of this is happening with Dobby and
Sad Man's parade the always is scheming
all for one sees an opportunity the
balance of power has clearly shifted in
the villain's favor and the heroes
currently have their hands full with
Dobby in toga this means that all for
one has the perfect opportunity to duck
out and join shigaraki on the UA
battlefield but before all for one can
make a break for it he is attacked by
Hawks Hawks noticed that all for one
seems to be in a hurry to get to
shigaraki as if he still doesn't fully
trust shigaraki to succeed it's as if
he's still afraid that something could
go wrong with tomura back at the UA all
for one pretty much admits as much
stating that despite all his many
modifications and mutations shigaraki is
still not quite complete at least not
yet there is still something important
that all for one must do and we can
assume that this is related to the fact
that shigaraki's own personality he
still hasn't been completely neutralized
by the all-for-one personality inside
him we know that little tenko shimura
and of course his alter ego tomora
shigaraki are still inside shigaraki's
body and this is preventing all for
one's personality from taking full
control of his shiny new vessel all for
one clearly wants to get to shigaraki
and make sure that the process has been
fully completed before his own original
body is inevitably rewound out of
existence Hawks calls out to Endeavor
and warns him that they can't allow the
villains to win this fight if they do
they will make their way to Deku and if
Deku Falls then all of Japan will fall
as Dobby rushes at Endeavor his father
vows to take charge of the situation
this time Endeavor will not look away as
Toya Burns this time he will not miss
his son's fiery demise this time he will
be right there until the end and that is
how this emotional and dramatic chapter
ends and man this was rough
Endeavor and Hawks are both clearly
injured and exhausted and they are
facing truly impossible odds I can't
help but think that this chapter was a
Prelude to one or both of them
sacrificing their lives in this battle
both of them have committed sins in
their past Endeavor was abusive towards
his family and Hawks killed a man who
thought of him as a friend now of course
we know why Hawks had to do it but Hawks
still feels guilty about it so I could
definitely see both Endeavor and Hawks
sacrificing their lives in order to
atone for their past sins with the
borderline impossible odds that the
heroes on goonga Mountain are currently
facing some serious casualties on the
hero side are definitely not out of the
realm of possibility in fact it's almost
unrealistic to expect all the heroes and
hero students to make it out of this
alive and that is the craziest part
about this stage of the made Chase story
when Deku unlocked his final Quirk gear
shift it looked like he might actually
defeat shigaraki and win the fight
things were looking up for the heroes
and thanks to headshot's magical bubble
thing it looked like bakugou would make
a full recovery and we would have a
happy ending now of course we were all
expecting something to happen to make
the ending less one-sided but what ended
up happening completely flipped the
script on all of us within the span of
like three chapters the villains
completely shifted the balance of power
and the situation went from the heroes
having a huge advantage to the villains
being on track to win the entire War
sure we could say that the heroes won
the Minor battles at kamino at okuto
Island then at the hospital but the two
most important battlefields are gunga
mountain and the UA and with Dobby's
flames and Sad Man's parade rampaging
across gunga and with kurogiri about to
help shigaraki at UA it really seems
like the heroes are about to collapse
hawksen and ever look like they're
preparing to sacrifice themselves to buy
some time for Deku and their sacrifices
could be just the beginning are you guys
surprised to see this drastic shift in
the balance of power on the battlefield
and do you think that we're about to see
some major hero deaths is this the end
of hawks or Endeavor or maybe both are
we about to see full power shigaraki
using all of his many quirks thanks to
an assist from kurogiri let me know what
you think down in the comments below and
if you want to know more about Dobby's
full story and why I think he might be a
human nomu hybrid don't ignore this
video that's all about him just click
the link on screen or in the description